en mitad del Bosque de fium en Ucrania
los árboles escondían un escenario de
terror cientos de cruces de una nueva
fosa común que los rusos dejaron a su
paso tras la recaptura ucraniana de la
ciudad
a mi lado hay una familia entera joven
el padre nacido en 1988 la madre en 1991
y su hija en 2016 junto a los abuelos
tenemos testimonios de lugareños que
afirman que todos murieron en un ataque
aéreo ruso
de los más de 400 cuerpos encontrados en
la mayoría civiles algunos mostraban
signos de violencia como manos atadas u
otros signos de tortura algo que ha
hecho resurgir las acusaciones de
crímenes de guerra contra Rusia y que
deberá ser confirmado por una
investigación internacional
encontramos 450 muertos enterrados Pero
hay otros entierros de muchas personas
separadas personas torturadas familias
enteras en ciertas zonas
territorial tras el encuentro de la fosa
común la comunidad internacional mostró
preocupación Naciones Unidas aseguró que
mandará un equipo para investigar la
zona y Estados Unidos condenó los hechos
cada vez que vemos Que Rusia se retira
de la zona ucranianas ocupadas vemos lo
que deja a su paso y este último
descubrimiento de Aparentemente más de
400 muertos en isium es un recordatorio
de ellos
este hallazgos es un mal de las fosas
comunes de hucha y Mario Paul y a los
más de 21.000 posibles crímenes de
guerra que Ucrania asegura haber
identificado desde el inicio del
conflicto y que Rusia ha negado
categóricamente